chris sale makes his second start coming
back from tommy john after that jewel of
the day when he returned
this one grounded to the left side and
past the diving devers and this one dies
in left field should be extra bases
easily for isaiah kind of for left big
turn around second but he holds up with
a one-out double
and there it is swung out of this for
strike three so sales certainly
following the scouting report
hey he strikes him out
well with the heat back to back k's one
man left
here's dane dunning has not given up
a run in the first inning in a month
here's the 1-2 pitch and suck the other
way down the line wicked line drive and
it's fair that's a fair ball
out of the warning track he gave his
second it pulls up with a double
[Applause]
that's going to get by his catcher
and kk easily drops into third base
there's a bullet
they'll get it done
sliding stand down the line by martin
with an rbi single for xander red sox
strike first one to nothing
boston hard hit and that's a fair ball
takes the shot off the sidewall
burgrat's on his way to third
throw comes into second
and a well stunned single by schwarber
but he's not reached in 18 straight
games
and the 0.1 and here's the ground ball
hit to the right side hernandez was in
the shift he comes in on the run makes
the play
and verdugo is retired the inning is
over dean dunning works around some
trouble he does allow one run but that's
it
it's a very sweet moment
for a guy meant an awful lot to folks
here in this city very very active
in charitable ventures really active in
the jimmy fund big act jimmy fund his
family was i think as popular as he was
he'll be back at some point
[Music]
this one is lifted right for that'll
fall in for a base hit for hernandez
pozo goes to second and the rangers have
first and second with one out
oh two
got him to go and he struck him out on
three pitches
three k's now for chris sale
high fly ball on the left
jd right there side retired two men left
that one stock down the right field
red sox are picking on that that's
another fair ball
vasquez to second garcia's throw will be
cut and he's got a double
[Music]
the heads up there by vasquez and a nice
play by brock holt so dunning in trouble
again
and there's a shot into right down for a
base hit
will still throw in a second not in time
red sox leading two to nothing
and the o2 and this one is grounded up
the middle but right at hernandez who
steps on the bag and whether or not he
was in time we're not sure but he plays
it safe and throws the ball over to
first anyway
that's in there for strike three
he sits down connor falefa admiring the
pitch and that is strikeout number four
for chris
oh don't get him angry
in there that was 95. that was his
fastest of the night he strikes up two
in a row
schwarberg connects he'll drill that one
high up there and that one's gonna catch
the top of the monster
he's gonna move into second base with a
two bagger
and he's two for two tonight
a line shot right at andy avanya is over
at first base he makes the play and so
jd martinez is retired
throws a 1-2 that bounces in the dirt
the runner takes off for third and he is
out the pitch didn't get very far away
from jonah heim just barely up the first
baseline schwarber decided to try it he
was out with room to
spare took one right over the second
base bag
so that ends sales string he had retired
six in a row it's the third hit
for the rangers
this one is
hit hard to the left side and through
the infield back-to-back base hits here
for the rangers shoulder heim with some
good base running gets over to third
easily
and they get a bunt here and it's popped
up oh that's in a
collision what is that run comes in to
score but they're going to send him back
because this is going to be interference
instead of liner and jd makes the catch
that was a rocket but he makes the catch
[Music]
here's a line chop from india banyas
into the right field gap he'll hold on
for a single but a lead off single here
for the rangers in the fifth
bogart is trying to start two
oh clearly he's out
the stretch see ya
that is a double play so they overturn
it
the grounds one to third base nice
backhanded play by brock holt over the
first in time
good stretch there by andy abanez and
[ __ ] hernandez
is retired
since this one is lifted to left field
and a nice play
by dj peters up against the green
monster
it's not easy to navigate that wall
the first time you come into town t.j
peters pretty happy as he should be that
was a very nice play
high fly driven down into the corner
and that ball is gone home run
xander touches them all for the 20th
time
a rising liner into the monster seats
blind down into the corner by martina as
a fair ball
red sox are painting the chalk lines
tonight
schwarber into third and puts on the
breaks
and a double another double for the red
sox martinez to second
there's a shot toward the wall
rising up to the monster
that's going to bring in both shorebirds
and martinez is in another red sox two
base hit that should do it for dunning
i guess so red sox on top five to
nothing the numbers for spores good body
of work for him this season 46 games
235 opponent avert and here it is the
3-2 and swung on a miss but gets away
from jonah hein
vasquez legging it out but not in time a
good play by andy avanyas and a good
throw from jonah high hansel robles
taking over for chris sale who can win
it
chris went the first five no runs five
hits five k's
and that's strike three
big heater at 97 to put him away
rider off the glove gonna flip it
get the out there back to first not in
time
he's gonna get garcia here two feet
throws behind him but meanwhile he
didn't catch it
ends up throwing the second that's not
the easiest double play on the two
nothing from spores swung on and hit
hard
shot into right
garcia races knocks it down
and the second base safely duran
got there rather quickly
[Applause]
the other way nice play here by ibanez
will go to the bag and get the out but
the run is in
he did deny [ __ ] a base head but not an
rbi
here's the 102 albania's ground ball hit
to the left side that's going to get
through the middle for a base hit so
it'll be a two out single for andy
ibanez
[Music]
[Applause]
by the red sox despite it getting just
inside the line
jd martinez goes down on strikes good
looking fastball from jarrell cotton
now there's a 3-2 change-up swung on him
missed and so alex verdugo is down
jerrell cotton throws up a zero with a
couple of strikeouts
he put him away back with a split
cut on him missed he strikes him out
with the splitter a one two three for
saumora
swung on a miss he struck him out with
that hook
yes
struck him out two down
one two
yes
that will help anybody's personality and
a red sox shut out texas six to nothing
nice way to start the series
you